it's the last day of the Harvest in
svalov in southern Sweden
but this wheat isn't destined for the
nation's bread baskets this is the test
field at the lant Menon farming
Cooperative where manager Tina Henriksen
has a mission
to breed crops that are future proof we
develop new varieties of wheat to make
sure that the varieties can still
produce as big yields as possible even
if the climate changes what we really
want to produce is varieties that are
robust to a lot of different climates
for her team it's been a decade-long
process
45 000 types of wheat have been whittled
down to an elite chief of just 10.
resistant to extreme heat drought and
floods
the knowledge could be crucial further
south the worst droughts in 500 years
have caused crops to fail in Italy
France and Germany
farming here used to be challenging
because of the cold not anymore
2022 has been a bumper Harvest for
Sweden an indication perhaps that their
agricultural industry can benefit at
least in the short term from the effects
of climate change
as the heat moves North Sweden's growing
season has become longer and warmer
septembers in the South have been two
degrees Celsius above the average in
recent years
farmers are aware that the good times
might not last long this Farm has been
record-breaking really we've had all the
all the great components related to a
good year we will probably see more
extreme weathers it seems like in this
region that once the rain comes it comes
more and once the dry weather comes it's
it's for longer periods changes in
climate bring changes in disease death
causes a toxin something that the
breeding process also tries to combat
Sweden's harvests may help with the
current food shortages in other
countries
but in the long term the biggest yields
may be in the lab fulleries Al Jazeera
sparlov Sweden